hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update according to some rumors a
new borderlands game set between the
first and the second one is going to be
coming out for xbox 360 ps3 and pc soon
according to a report on games points
now calm Gearbox Software president
randy pitchford previously stated the
borderlands 3 was not in development
teasing on twitter i said we are not
developing borderlands 3 I did confirm
more for the borderlands franchise
though as for this untitled and
unannounced borderlands game's story
games points now calm says the title
will revolve around a younger handsome
Jack and let you play is one of his four
lieutenants Athena the gladiator Wilhelm
the enforcer Misha the law bringer and
frag trap said to be a militarized
claptrap the game is reportedly set on
the moon of Elvis and Hyperion's iconic
h-shaped base from Borderlands 2 the
title is said to offer a bazillion
weapons to choose from including a cryo
class of guns which will allow you to
freeze and blast your enemies the
rumored Borderlands title will also
feature jetpacks according to the report
and oxygen is said to play a huge role
in the game the oxygen resources will
reportedly be bootable and you'll need
to manage your o2 levels to survive the
report claims of course all of this is
rumor right now and 2k has not
officially said one way or the other how
true or accurate any of this is but as
soon as there's any new borderlands news
you'll be able to find it on gamespot
you